the longer you've been in hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by
but the thing is is that for every rule
in hollywood there's always an exception
what if it's been five or ten years and
someone's not any closer to their quote
unquote dream and they come here from
somewhere else
i think that question
has nuance
because i've worked with a lot of people
who have been here for five or ten years
who feel
nowhere near their dreams and who are
really struggling
but
if we're really honest
it's not like absolutely nothing has
happened in five or ten years so maybe
they're not where they want to be yet
they haven't booked that big tv show yet
if they're an actor or you know they
haven't booked that big project whatever
their craft is
um
but it's very i don't think i've ever
met any artist out here who
literally has not
done a single thing in their career in
five or ten years unless they got a day
job that became their sole
you know priority and then they just
worked on
let me get a promotion at my day job let
me try to move up here and that becomes
the priority so the only time i've ever
seen like literally nothing happen is
when the day job becomes the priority
over the dream and they kind of let the
dream go for all those years
but of my clients that i've worked with
i think it's important
to celebrate what you have achieved and
to take like even if you're not where
you want to be and it's been years
take a look at what you've actually done
even if it feels small to you
because i think that um
if you can start shifting your focus
onto what you have done instead of what
you haven't it'll help you feel more
confident it'll help you feel
you know just better energy you'll feel
proud of yourself you'll feel
better and so
i think that will lead to
more things happening
um now that being said you know when i
work with people there's so many things
that we can take a look at it like you
know why are you not where you want to
be yet and so we can take a look at
what are the strategies that you either
haven't tried at all or that you have
been procrastinating you know that's a
big thing um or that
there's so many pieces sorry i feel like
this is gonna be a long answer but
there's so many pieces to it it's like
with the strategy piece it's like
are there things that you haven't tried
and then if there are let's take a look
at why right and that all comes down to
your belief system
the fears that you have the doubts that
you have whether or not you believe in
yourself um and and that can get very
nuanced as well you know we get deep
into what is really truly holding you
back
from doing some of these strategic moves
that you really haven't done yet
and then another thing that i've noticed
with some of my clients
is that the longer you have been in the
industry and i always say hollywood but
i don't say hollywood as in the location
i call like the industry hollywood so
the longer you've been in hollywood if
you've been in hollywood for five or ten
years
you end up having more limiting beliefs
than somebody who is brand new
because someone who is brand new
they're so green and they're so naive
that they take more risks because
they're not afraid of doing the wrong
thing because they don't know what the
wrong thing is
whereas someone who's been here for a
long time and has been in the industry
for a long time you know more about how
the industry works and you might know
more about like behind the scenes and
what relationships are important and
what you need to be doing
and then because of that you you lose
your sense of
risk-taking and being bold and putting
yourself out there you know
um in a in a i hate to say in a risky
way but it's all about taking you know
it's all about putting yourself out
there and taking risks and so
the longer you've been in hollywood
the more rules you are trying to live by
but the thing is is that for every rule
in hollywood there's always an exception
so
you don't necessarily want to use these
rules to hold you back
and when i say rules just for an example
in the industry
you know some of my actor clients when
they are wanting to if they need to get
a new agent or a new manager
one of the rules in hollywood is you
should never contact representation and
reach out to them during pilot season
right there's like certain times of the
year that's busier maybe the beginning
of episodic or you know when pilot
season is going on and you're not
supposed to reach out
right and so it's just because you know
how the industry works you've been in
the industry a long time you know that
there's a pilot season you know that
people are really busy during pilot
season
but there's always going to be an
exception to that rule that rule is not
really set in stone
and so if you follow that rule because
you think you're you know you have this
knowledge about how the industry works
and you want to
be good and follow these rules that you
think you know
in that process you are stopping
yourself from taking a risk
and i've had many clients book agents
during pilot season and then are able to
go out for pilot season
so that's just a little example you know
of i think some of the things that hold
people back in hollywood the more they
know
the more it tends to hold them back and
then also with that there's a third part
of this that i've really noticed with
some of my clients
is that
the more you know
the more boxes you try to fit into
and i feel like that's just a big thing
in hollywood that a lot of people
struggle no matter if you're a writer a
director um you know working behind the
scenes somehow an actor
you know even my production designer
boss couple years ago fell into that of
like how can i you know oh i do drama
and they don't think i can do comedy
and so
i have found that a lot of people get
stuck in these boxes because they're
trusting other people to tell them
what box they fit into
you know like with actors it all all
starts in the beginning with headshots
i've seen this so many times where an
actor is told to put their headshot on
facebook and ask everyone on facebook
what what roles can you see me as with
this headshot you know what shows do you
see me in according to this headshot
and that's a super common thing right
and if they're not asking their facebook
friends they're asking their agents
their managers their you know their
teachers
but every time you do that you are
asking somebody else to tell you how to
live your dream
and you're letting somebody else dictate
what roles you go out for what projects
you get to be a part of and you
completely lose your voice
and so i think that when people struggle
in the five to ten year range i think
that that sometimes depending on the
person you know plays a part where all
these years maybe they've been trying to
pursue the industry
in these boxes that they were told they
should be in
but it never feels good and it never
feels aligned and so they struggle you
know i have one of my clients really
struggle with that and you know she's
done such beautiful work as we work
together for the past two years and
she's really come into
her own right like you know she's really
connected with
who she really is now and who she wants
to be and not who hollywood has been
telling her to be all these years
and then that leads to more exciting
opportunities because you're more
confident and standing on in your own
um
more often and you know that will bleed
into the work that you do even though it
sounds counterintuitive like oh erica
but hollywood loves the boxes
stepping out of that is somehow going to
help you succeed
i think yes i think it's about
alignment and
and being yourself a hundred percent i
think that will always lead to more
success
i love what you're saying
what if what if we can't accurately see
ourselves because like i knew someone
who
was was auditioning and she was doing
well and she was about to turn 30 which
when you look back at it from an older
age is not old at all but a friend or so
she thought said oh let me see your
headshots
and so she showed this friend and the
friend said oh and he gave her this
feedback he said look
you're getting near 30 so you're going
to want to aim for mom rules
so maybe tone down the sexy factor a
little bit and
that was sort of eye-opening to this
person because they still saw themselves
as this
you know not sex kitten but they just
saw themselves as not as the mom
and so i'm just wondering how much is it
that we're blinded by ourselves because
we can't really see ourselves accurately
sometimes
or
was she allowing this person to really
tell her how to be
yeah i think i mean it's a great
question and and i'm sure that you know
every agent or casting director or
whatever will disagree with me but i
think that
the more we
buy into the boxes the more we are
helping perpetuate the problem
and so i think that
you know with the rise of streamers like
netflix and hulu and amazon
we are getting to see more complex
stories which is amazing because with
the networks of abc nbc you know those
are likely following formulas that have
worked before and they're a little more
of stereotype when it comes to
characters and content and you know and
story
but
because there's so much more content now
available with the streaming i really do
feel that we are finally moving into an
area of hollywood where we are getting
more complex storytelling and so to me
like the mom right you turn 30 and then
you need to play the mom it's like could
you be a super complex character that
happens to have a child
right and so i think that we need to
stop
letting hollywood define us as the mom
um
even if that feels hard you know even if
you feel like you're getting the advice
from someone trusted who's been in the
industry i think it is partly on us
to stop perpetuating
those kinds of things that happen you
know
like the client that i was talking about
she just came out as non-binary
and that can be really scary as an actor
you know because she's having to explore
with her representation what that means
in terms of what roles she wants to go
out for
but
to her for her to even have that
conversation with her representation
she is breaking through
the the boxes and the hollywood stuff
you know of stereotypes and she is
challenging it because she is saying
this is who i am this is who i know that
i am
and so let's explore what kind of
complex roles i can play
so
i guess to answer your question about
you know
finding ourselves if we feel like maybe
we've lost ourselves i think
you have to begin by tuning out
everything
tuning out the noise don't listen to me
don't listen to other people you have to
get back to yourself
and
what your dream truly is you know the
very first chapter of my book
i invite people to write down
everything they would love to happen in
their career everything that you dream
of you know get back to
that dream you had in your heart when
you were a kid or whenever it was that
you decided you wanted to pursue this
dream get back to that
and connect to that and really you know
some of my clients too they'll
they'll study they'll do some research
and watch you know some shows that they
really love and start to explore what
excites them you know when you watch
this do you feel really excited because
you'd love to play a complex role like
this person
um
so
i think that process involves you know
you
um reconnecting with your own intuition
and tuning out the noise and get really
true to who you are
and decide
that you are worthy and are capable of
succeeding as who you are
even if others tell you no you need to
play the mom or know you need to fit in
this box
you